All kinds of modern,
amazing things were happening at the
beginning of the 20th century,
especially in the United States of
America and,
and the movies and Hollywood.
We're one of those things that we kind
of,
uh,
I think have lost track of how,
what a quantum shift watching movies,
uh,
represented for the experience of life.
I'm sure there,
there had been actors in plays before,
but,
um,
uh,
the,
the first of all,
the glut of entertainment that suddenly
existed in the almost phantasmagorical
quality of watching real people moving
around that were in front of you,
but in some nether world and film and
they were really in London or,
or,
or in India or,
uh,
the Yukon or whatever.
The,
the,
and,
and time was suddenly changed that when
from childhood to adulthood,
everything about the cinema was w w we
have to understand what a huge change
that was and,
and how,
how mutable it seemed to make reality.
So you take that,
that the,
the fact of cinema,
TV,
video,
everything we now for five generations
have taken as the way things are.
So that that gave us,
gave us,
and especially Americans,
obviously French people and English
people as well,
but this,
this idea that,
that reality was mutable.
Then on top of that,
and with that you have this,
this,
uh,
celebrity culture,
where,
where celebrity itself is,
uh,
there are my orders of magnitudes.
Suddenly more celebrities.
There were,
you know,
in the 19th century and earlier there
were,
there were a famous people,
but a few of them and,
and,
uh,
and now there were hundreds and then
eventually thousands of famous people
who were now famous for pretending to be
somebody else,
actors.
That was a strange new condition.
And,
and so,
uh,
for a long time,
for much of the 20th century,
uh,
people looked up to,
to,
to movie stars because they seem to have
real potency in this world where,
uh,
individuals seen more and more part of a
mass here.
Here were the people because they were
famous.
And because we watched them and stared
at them and dreamed about them,
we're,
we're the,
the little,
we're like superheros or demi gods.
So by the end of the 20th century or
before the end of the 20th century,
who wouldn't?
If you're,
uh,
an American,
steeped in this movie and then
television culture,
I want to be famous.
Maybe there's no reason for you to be
famous,
but my God,
only famous people have real agency in
the world.
So,
uh,
we got to to that where,
where fame is own,
uh,
end.
Um,
you also again,
uh,
there's advertising everywhere,
but advertising and the advertising
industry,
we're really an American invention
starting way back in the 18 hundreds,
when,
uh,
for instance,
the political candidate,
presidential candidate,
William Henry Harrison,
was the first marketed or advertised
presidential candidate.
He,
he was this,
this rich guy who they wanted to rebrand
as a humble guy,
had grown up in a log cabin.
So log cabins became his,
his,
his icon,
his branding symbol.
And they made real big ones and little
ones and,
and liquor and,
and,
and facial creams in,
in log cabin containers.
And they made chants and songs and he
won by a landslide over a guy who was
actually of humble origins.
So,
uh,
advertising as part of this fantasy
industrial complex that is so American
and so defining of America,
uh,
has,
has become,
has been a big part of what we're
talking about as well.
Disneyland.
Uh,
I love Disneyland.
but,
but it,
it became when it was created in the
1950s,
uh,
not just as a little amusement park to,
to promote Walt Disney's animated films,
but as this other version of reality
that was more,
that was real in the,
it was there,
you could go there and buy things that
these old fashion shops on main street,
USA with actors,
but they were selling you stuff.
Uh,
what's,
what happened in Disneyland and starting
in 1955 did not stay there.
And that Main Street USA,
most of all became a kind of model for
how you build shopping centers,
how you build a suburbs,
how you theme everything,
uh,
from restaurants to hotels to,
to two shops to clubs.
So,
uh,
the,
the Hollywood idea and,
and what came before in pop culture and
what came after and,
and as it expanded to sort of subsume
all of American life is,
is,
uh,
is a big part of,
of,
of how we as Americans have become so
iffy about telling what's fake from
what's real,
what's true from what's false.